[Music]
Jesus Christ in addition to a full 46
seconds of logos DC is now turning to a
marvel style showpiece that checks all
their characters and fat were bad enough
they have the balls to include in Green
Lantern also DC Comics listen they'll be
a few times that I'm gonna compare this
to a much better Marvel movie so strap
in ready okay
discount spider-man homecoming opening
oh man I used to say that hope is like a
car keys easy to lose let's review the s
on Superman's uniform it's not a mess
but it's a symbol that stands for hope
and much like your car keys hope is
usually close by except when Superman is
saving someone in France while you're in
the middle of the woods trying to start
your Jeep Wrangler to get away from
rednecks the axe wielding redneck then
your car keys are not usually close by
gave them to Steve's aunt who was thrown
into the s-shape Hope River near Kent
Falls so I think I understand your
simile huh I've never seen a production
studio named as a direct warning of a
movie before zack snyder awesomely
depicts the news that Superman is dead
by showing us a newspaper that pigeons
are pumping on our Lee which is about as
much respect as I have for the nonsense
ending of Batman V Superman oh cool
someone's committing a blatant crime and
Gotham City I love it when they play the
hits I hope they do Bruce's parents died
after this one brings the house down
I'm positive Batman had scoped out this
building and found that no one was
behind this window that he's goading the
thug into shooting up safety first that
bats you know what I love best about the
Batman action of the previous films the
copious use of slow motion a man jumps
off a building assuming that when he
tackles a parademon in midair it will be
able to take on the new weight and keep
flying also after all this Batman ends
up on top of the same building how did
that happen
what the hell no well Jeremy you're
supposed to be in character when you say
this line good it's time then well it's
really only time for Batman and Wonder
Woman but you wanted to go ahead and
challenge the Avengers franchise even
though there are no solo movies for the
other three yet look I know the whole
world loves Superman and all but hanging
a banner on no trade on not only is
there no fucking way that would happen
look how the execution is also these
banners are hanging on honor of
Superman's death I'm cynical enough to
think it's DC advertising for the next
Superman movie this is absolutely
nothing scene shown in the opening
credits illustrates that when you enjoy
putting slow motion in your movies too
much you wrap it of any impact it can
have the idea that this asshole kicking
a fruit cart scene is on some
slow-motion level of drama is goddamn
infuriating antal arias somehow joss
whedon found future footage of himself
in 2026 and included it in this movie
what an extremely politely British way
to die I know this movies gotten a lot
of flack for upskirting
honestly I think the amount of up
shooting is overlooked look all I'm
saying is Wonder Woman is shot
completely different in this movie than
when a woman was at the helm and no I am
NOT above perviness but this movie isn't
red Shoe Diaries Wonder Woman of desire
an unproduced script I wrote in 1995
under the pseudonym Johnny spokes this
is a movie where Wonder Woman is an
equal super hero to all the men and it's
guaranteed we won't be seeing any dudes
filmed in a similar manner back to the
dark ages and the safety of holy Fair
King what if dude knows for sure they're
gonna blow stuff why even use a timer
isn't a timer for motherfuckers who want
to escape
okay Wonder Woman you can stop posing
and defeat evil now one Wonder Woman the
following scene is ruined by no less
than ten cuts back and forth between
Wonder Woman doing her acrobatics and
Roose Bolton shooting at her not to
mention how she manages to block bullets
while she's turned the other way and
since one can Wonder Woman do flash
stuff anyway
meanwhile a different ridiculously
expensive set also Bruce rides in on a
horse walk some distance to a cliff and
I guess he ends up rappelling down this
thing to a town where people know
Aquaman but this is Bruce Wayne the idea
that he couldn't find this place through
the air or by some special glacier
busting bat ship to land closer to it is
ludicrous
hey Aquaman here you can talk to fish I
can't wait to see how Aquaman sea powers
somehow factor into beating an army of
flying para demons from space that
probably gets sick when they go near
water anyway I don't mind the ocean guys
how about if they boil just like a bat
you're out of your mind Bruce Wayne I
think having three separate discussions
here that have nothing to do with one
another is there a reason that this
version of Alfred dresses like he
ordered everything from the eddie bauer
catalog i mean
cargo pants seriously on this is the
days where mom's biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins wait are they
saying this movie is in the same
timeline as Batman Returns
because that raises a lot of questions
hurry it up will ya haha get it because
he's the flash and this guy doesn't know
he's the flash but seriously what is it
about superheroes where they end up
running into the biggest assholes on
earth and they aren't even looking for
them you can have a life all these
characters so little time whatever is
coming that requires such a team
apparently can be beaten easily with all
this backstory to cover and they haven't
even tried to resurrect Superman or
fight him yet essentially they let the
comic book fans fill in the gaps for
caring about these characters lazily
introducing them and dropping them off
at a movie theater while their parents
shopped at the mall didn't think you
were ready for them to know what for
them to see the monster you are not a
monster it's weird that you thought I
meant me not really the logical
discussion you were having about you and
what others might feel when they see you
definitely made it sound like you we're
talking about being a monster
oh cool the most curious
I mean themed spark idea I mean simple
skini
can be thumbing nut I couldn't I just
named this Amazon Ireland yeah man if
that box opens we're gonna shoot the god
of it with arrows also a warm welcome to
Steppenwolf the main baddie that you
will forget as soon as this movie is
over I honestly didn't think the CGI
bodies could get any worse than doomsday
especially ones that are essentially
humanoid but DC once again finds away a
bunch of parademons come through a
portal then they start shooting up the
place and a whole bunch of whatever
occurs I'd almost rather the director
put up an old-time You silent film
intertidal up on screen that says BAM
kazooie the Amazons get boomed and I
then watch a dreary action piece like
this take place also I watched this
action scene frame by frame just to get
a sense of what this film thinks it's
showing us and I have ultimately decided
that nobody who made this film really
knows a to seeing the mother box get
lassoed away makes me wonder why
Steppenwolf didn't just grab it and run
you landed right next to it he has a
nifty portal why all the trouble
fighting the Amazons keep it moving
what the hell is this plan give the
all-important life box to some character
we've never met then tell her to ride
really fast that way is this really the
only contingency plan they had for this
box for the last several thousands of
years oh no the old spark I mean that
does Iraq I mean the rabbit's foot I
mean mother box is out in the open so
wait does an arrow have the load-bearing
capability to pull something as heavy as
the mother box as it flies through the
air also box also I guess this is
actually a clever plan but what the are
these ladies doing all the way up there
they know they don't have the box when
they could have actually been helpful in
the fight back by Steppenwolf did they
seriously expect these arrow shenanigans
to work or are we just going for a cool
shot with no thought behind rather where
all these Amazons while Steppenwolf was
trying to take the box if he even had
half these soldiers standing outside
while Steppenwolf tried to chase after
the relay racers they could have ended
this does this movie explain how
Steppenwolf can use the Bifrost at any
time or place that he wants I mean I'm
sure there's a comic explanation in New
Gods number one from 1970 but if I'm
gonna look that men won't know what it
means men won't she will damn it Queen
this is no time to be playing the
pronoun game this janitors wife had some
strong words for the aliens
she says stole her man what's with the
glib attitude man everyone in the world
knows aliens exist now from Superman
doomsday is on so why treat this woman
like she's crazy an alien that only
comes
down to probe some random dude is the
least of your worries also movie has
time for this and yeah I know the story
is about the janitor Cyberdyne I mean
STAR Labs but the fact that they decided
to update us in tabloid fashion with his
foul mouth wife makes his disappearance
mean even less to me you know the banks
jump like a cougar if you missed by a
dime jump like a cougar if you miss by a
dime well I'll see if she'll take your
calls so it's a shame that's racist
anyway sad card coming back here at all
I can imagine after arrival and
nocturnal animals this must have seemed
like amateur hour he said you could
smell a story further away than he could
hear speaking of hearing they're having
a pretty casual conversation about
Lois's relationship with Superman here
even though Martha's known as Clark
Kent's mom so anyone that's half
eavesdropping which should be pretty
common in the newsroom should have had
the biggest scoop in years right about
now it was about seeing the engine of
the world it still man I swear to god
eighty percent of the first 30 minutes
of this movie is main character has
one-on-one conversation with side
character about something sad ah I said
light went from blue to red he's been
iRobot it rotten Shia oh hey I didn't
see you there I was replacing the hose
on this giant aircraft that I work on
all by myself and yet it still runs
perfectly it's boring but it's part of
my life you know I've paid millions of
dollars for this building security yeah
it's expensive
I guess diana has ninja powers now too
she can crack bruises AKA batman
security system without being detected
did she have time to learn that they
called him Steppenwolf the end of worlds
he was a long way from the rockin sounds
of magic carpet ride and born to be wild
but sometimes you can find inspiration
from the destruction of planets
nightmare creatures who feed him fear
these so called nightmare creatures
significantly lose their nightmare
status when you see them flying around
like gnats wielding laser guns also do
they really feed on fear well they just
do what they're told they did okay
against the Amazons and I don't find
them to be a particularly fearful group
I have no idea what's in them power they
don't contain power they are power o
other worlds how did you get the
lanterns to show up during this battle
did they just show up on their own this
whole movie is like a crash course while
we literally watch the DCE you crash to
the ground Sam say drove him and the
disgrace of his first retreat
yeah but wasn't he already a little
crazy like didn't you just say his sole
purpose was to conquer fools do you get
any madder than that both
sealed and guarded insecure strong homes
okay fine
you had the forethought to separate the
mother boxes and put them into secure
strongholds but why on display like
museum artifacts and when I try to
destroy them earn them the fires of
Mount Doom the box of men was buried in
secret one of the lanterns take the box
you left a powerful artifact in the
hands of King regular-ass dudes and
they're burying it in a van down by the
river we're asking people we done know
to risk their lives what was that story
you just told about all the heroes
banding together to fight Stefan well
we're all those people friends before
then Quicksilver or flash or neo is
doing something really fast so we have
to slow it down to show their
perspective cliche what is brunch you
wait in line for an hour for essentially
lunch Jesus Christ Barry is arguably the
best thing about this movie but the poor
guy has gotta read bad stand up lines
like this to make him seem extra nerdy
Diana and Victor meet face to face but
why here why in public do what you do
how would Dianna know this cyborg
himself doesn't even know what he can do
and it's not like this is a set of
powers that anyone seen before and do
fine I mean it's always the same for a
long time every protagonist in this
movie at least what I lost someone I
loved once you might say that I pined
for him also look I know the power of
love better than anyone except Huey
Lewis but Steve died a hundred years ago
just because the movie came out five
months before this doesn't mean Diana
has to still be hung up on that asshole
what's this
from disguise why would the parademons
attack a fishing boat when they've
discovered the location of the mother
box underwater
yes we've got to inform Aquaman of the
impending danger somehow but the wanton
destruction of these parademons makes no
sense geez you think someone close to
the ocean would be more concerned about
littering if the parademons tore through
that fisherman's boat then Aquaman saved
him took him back to the bar and had a
drink before coming back to Atlantis why
aren't there already here is there any
real explanation as to how Steppenwolf
knows exactly where these mother boxes
are on earth and if he can transport
with impunity why'd it take them so long
to get to Atlantis and why are all the
armies caught completely on oh oh you
know what never mind
I'm sure it's all addressed in the
Schneider cut
huh looks like I ever heard a noise
apparently Aquaman's abilities under
water include punching and kicking holy
that was easy
there were like 3 people in Atlantis
guarding the supposedly super
well-guarded mother box might as well
have done what the humans did these
assholes need to create a space without
water to communicate this is some
goddamn balls where is the underwater
telepathy what makes these heroes so
special underwater the firstborn beloved
Queen atlanna um are you guys going to
address the fact that the mother box was
stolen and that's a huge development we
saw the Amazons fight hard to keep it in
their possession and the Atlanteans
baddest tenacious is an Atlanta team in
the playoffs mother I see why you waited
to summon the Kryptonians death plunged
this timid world into such terror
Superman is overrated that I've said it
not only was there a time Superman
didn't exist and it would have made the
most sense for the mother boxes to call
you then but even when Superman was
saving people on the regular most people
never got help from him he couldn't be
everywhere it was and he spent most of
his time in Metropolis he also have to
factor in all the people who were scared
that Superman existed because of what it
meant for the world at large
that's why Batman V Superman was like
watching c-span for three hours finds
our lost mod wait is he asking the
minions to do this hasn't Steppenwolf
found the other two pretty much on his
own she really outsourcing now suspect
was a giant bat with huge fangs Oh
amazing DC Marvel crossover here as Jay
jonah Jameson finally makes his
appearance can't wait until there's a
power struggle between he and Perry
White during the Daily Planet Daily
Bugle merger what a visually arresting
shop tells the story of Bruce Wayne
deboarding his private jet in an
uncertain world of Galkin asses
Batman jumps down from this gargoyle as
he is wont to do but why did Wonder
Woman and flash show up to the rooftop
like normal people
why did Batman need the grand entrance
at all do you think Commissioner Gordon
wants to tell Batman cut the man I've
seen you a hundred times you're just not
to press me anymore easily back to
Braxton Island between the two cities
because in case you forgot that book
from the last movie Gotham and
metropolis are separated by a very short
distance with just a small body of water
between them you really think well I
understand Batman in one woman have
methods the cyborgs have the ability to
leave stealthily it all sets up this
pretty funny flash moment I guess you
the mother bucks percent is only
constraints that Steppenwolf wasn't all
over star lamps from the very beginning
if he can smell the mother box which by
the way new but even more important if
the mother box cries out for him why
hasn't he found cyborg a guy made from
the mother box faster than this that guy
is here right now just tell me the rules
first off how does flash make everything
he touches go as fast as him second if
he has to wear the suit to stop from
catching fire
why didn't Silas third doesn't Silas now
have all the whiplash and this parademon
this kicking Batman's ass just imagine
if there were more than one of them
attacking at the same time it's not
thanks Alfred
but I'll take it from here please keep
firmly in mind that the all-mother
powerful Steppenwolf is literally
sitting there with his thumb up his ass
while the Justice League snaps pithy
one-liners oh cool
Aquaman showed up was he just waiting
outside the tunnel and hoping that
someone would blow a big hole in it so
that he could join the other justice
leaguers yellow distraction moment then
why the hell did you bring all those
humans here to find out where the mother
box is shouldn't you go find them Bale
yes and while you were virtually in the
same amount of peril from the rising
flood water as a few seconds ago yet we
will advance to the next scene without
acknowledging any other all he needs now
is the last box of men Narayana
he doesn't have it but I decided to take
it out of its hiding place and show it
to you guys out in the open he was doing
fine where it was but I figured I'd ramp
up the danger some more the parademons
are all surrounding this house with the
Russian family in it but how are they
kept from going inside sure they boarded
up their windows and barricaded the
doors but unless we saw them the windows
were not boarded up and they would have
been easy for parademons to break and
access I also call both on barricades
and boarded up windows keeping these
guys from breaking in so all of this is
worthless to me goddamn even the
elevator ride to the Batcave looks
vacant why would you choose to make your
elevator ride look fake it movie you
have no idea what kind of power you're
dealing with even if there's a fraction
of a chance Jesus Christ Bruce what is
it with you and your low percentage of
chances last time you said some boat
that if there was even a 1% chance of
Superman being an enemy you had to take
it as an absolute certainty now you
think you can control a mother box to
resurrect the very same Superman because
there might be a fraction of a chance
without even thinking of the potential
consequences technologies like any other
power without reason without heart it
destroys us like the iPhone we are not
enough yeah but it seemed
though let's look at this objectively
and forget that a Justice League movie
without Superman is like journey without
Steve Perry sure it's not quite the same
but it's still got a lot of people who
can get the job done like if the writers
came up with a way that this crew could
win with all the resources Bruce has
along with the combined superpowers of
all the others you'd be sold on that
right and Arnel Pineda it might not have
super-strength but tell me he can't fly
when he sings open arms
you lose something when he died there is
four I'll have a contingency plan for
that Lois it's Lois even though
Offerman's literally talking about Supes
losing the part that would allow him to
recognize the people he loves Lois
I swear I'm pretty sure this is
Amazonian first what kind of assholes
would let the one picture Clark was
buried with fall into the goddamn goo
it's not like they didn't see that it's
pretty hilarious to me that they're
pushing Clark down into this still
wearing the suit from his funeral not
only when we return as Superman but I'll
also have a dangerous fashion sense that
will make evildoers cower and fear the
mother boxes ready you have to charge it
the moment it touches the fluid it's not
that flash can't get there the moment
the box hits the fluid it's that there's
a hilariously arbitrary deadline in the
first place Wow cool the supers most of
time their caper to happen just before
dawn since it's now daylight and they
went in when it was super dark also let
me get this straight
what is the timeline of this movie they
met with Gordon on the roof right before
they attacked Steppenwolf in the harbor
so those events happen on the same night
then later that night they got the
mother box leading to the confrontation
in the Batcave which I guess happened
the next morning since it's light
outside even though you know it's in a
cave then we smash cut to flash in
cyborg in Kansas digging up Clark's
grave later that night and finally we
journey back to Metropolis which is
definitely not Gotham for these Superman
is Anse at the end of that night so
movies both telling me all this happened
within roughly 24 hours and that
Steppenwolf has been doing Jack the
whole time
glad Superman is alive so that now this
movie can officially start 35 minutes
before deaths but where did the rest of
his suit go well at least it kept his
pants Wonder Woman definitely would have
been pg-13 naked she went through this
hey em guys very important mother box to
retrieve it landed on somebody's car
hello very important thing okay this is
an example of how fun this movie could
be and so we will knock off a sin for
this very good moment from a
not-so-great film they helped took
Batman this long I know he doesn't have
the SuperSpeed that the others have but
it's the length of a public park man
what happened all that CrossFit he did
in the last movie Clark
Weiss Clark pissed off at Bruce again
sure they had that big fight in BBS but
by the end of that movie they banded
together and had no problems working to
take doomsday out so his last memory
should be all like hey did we win st.
Martha man just say Martha fuck
thank God they gave Lois more to work
with in this movie than just a facility
I'm sorry I could say that with a
straight face
well Supes is awake I guess we'll give
him all the time he needs to get his
head straight and hope that Steppenwolf
will wait to enact his final plan when
he's ready to roll another box no she no
fucking this should have been mission
number 1a after it flew out of STAR Labs
at least mission number one B it's not
like all of you had to uncle Superman's
awesome abs so you can't find them or
maybe you don't want to since this keeps
happening in every fucking movie I'll go
all caps protagonists have unnecessary
fight before the climax of the movie
cliche sure the fate of the world hangs
in the balance but at least there's time
for Clark to meditate and some corn
seriously this movie has 25 minutes left
Steppenwolf is probably the least
villain ever I'm the idiot I left but
I'm back now I have these two are
reconciling but that's gonna be a pretty
awkward mustache ride you call Bob
whatever you want to call it dude I
guess it's got to be weird to get your
first post-death boner for us that's the
deal I was pretty tense well I guess I
do own one so there can cool now sure
Lois cleared some cobwebs for Clark here
but within minutes he's gone from
homicidal to chummy with bats and here I
didn't think a reconciliation could get
any more annoying than the end of civil
war right last time Steppenwolf had the
unity they had to stop it right away or
the planet would go to literal hell but
this time he's taking so much time that
a random village family can escape in
that town my whole life being part of
something bigger like this this is
ultimately one of the very few bright
spots of humor in this movie but it all
depends on a Wonder Woman just laying
her lasso down anywhere be Aquaman not
seeing that magical before he sits down
see the lasso activating even though
it's not last sewing anything and Dee
has asked completely covering the rope
so that we don't have the reveal until
after his speech seriously who the fuck
is this family why do they matter I've
honestly lost count but I'm gonna
estimate this is the 143rd hero shot in
this movie I'm gonna take out
tower knock down that shield oh wait you
mean that thing is powered by some sort
of tower it is truly insane when a
powerful ancient character needs a tower
to create a shield dome making a hole in
the shield is way too easy
taking out the tower is way too easy
I thought the parademons were attracted
to fear not sound in fact didn't this
sound just make the parademon go crazy
so why would it pursue the sound yeah
maybe to destroy whatever is making it
sure but you set these things up to
follow fear and ended up making them
simply annoyed by police sirens minutes
Hey how does she know that did she talk
to the ballerina Bruce brought to dinner
in the dark night while I watch Aquaman
Russell with these parademons I'm at a
total loss as to what he can actually do
in this battle that is not in water so
is he just like really strong or
something is that it couldn't Bruce have
hired John Cena to be in the Justice
League thanks for the lift
cyborg who moves pretty fast need flash
to take him anyway you know what I
wanted to see from this movie Batman
stealing a gun and using it to off bug
creatures that's how you put asses in
the seats you're all too weak well I
believe in truth I'm also a big fan of
justice thank god Steppenwolf set him up
Superman's been thinking up this
entrance line the whole way over here
oh man Jason Momoa has officially become
the will smith of the Justice League
oh no if only Steppenwolf would try any
of his tricks instead of punching or
kicking considering he's like pretty
much a god right
civilians there's too many of them dude
can't one woman use her newly formed
flash powers that we saw at the
beginning of this movie to help Barry
why are you easily disposed of
Steppenwolf and why didn't you just go
ahead and disable that guy when you had
the chance
Slovo exhibits 67,000 and nine of
Superman being way way too powerful is
him being able to keep up with the flash
what makes Flash special the Superman
could do the same thing I mean all he's
got now is that he can make an
electrical charge but I'm sure Superman
starts wearing fur he can accomplish
that in short order too
so Barry help the only family we're
supposed to care about in the truck and
Superman saved a whole apartment complex
someone driving the apartment complex
these are supposedly people who were
trying to get out of town right so
Steppenwolf is just no longer difficult
huh it was kicking everyone's ass before
Superman showed up but now that's
is out of the picture again Wonder Woman
and Aquaman can hold their own with very
little trouble oh yeah
Teen Titans know now that they took out
Steppenwolf the village immediately
turns into the shimmer from annihilation
I really fucking hate this family looks
like Bruce decided to pay for the Kent
farm so that Martha could have her house
back just wondering though why didn't he
do this sooner I know it was cool to pay
for the funeral and the last movie and
maybe he thought he'd done enough but it
was clearly a dick move to not do this
before now darkness the truest darkness
wait movie Lois Lane aeration here's the
rock III ending for nerds alright stop
joking around Luthor I'm gonna have to
come in there so Lex broke out of the
Super Max prison
smuggled the dude in that looked like
him then escaped onto his yacht to set
up a meeting with Deathstroke why
couldn't we have seen that mister this
movie shouldn't we have a league of our
own as long as the characters are never
developed and are thrown into a two hour
movie and we're supposed to just know
what their powers are I'm all in
[Music]
did you know that Batman servers were
once hacked by the Legion of Doom nearly
toppling the Justice League only Bruce
Wayne and been running Nord VPN at the
time nor word VPN that's Virtual Private
Network uses their military-grade
encryption services to keep your
information safe from hackers malware
and the Legion of Doom and for a limited
time you can get 75% off a three-year
plan at Nord VPN comm / cinemasins
if you use the code cinemasins a check
out you can get an extra month of
service for free use that extra cash to
buy yourself something fancy three words
for you treat yo self Nord VPN also
offers 24/7 customer support and is
totally risk-free with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so if you're like
me and spend too much time in the
weirdest corners of the internet or
you're just trying to keep Wonder
Woman's secret identity under wraps and
you really need to check out Nord VPN go
to Nour VPN comm slash cinemasins and
use codes cinemasins to keep your
browsing secure for just $2.99 a month
and an extra month for free don't be
like Batman protect yourself online
today it began with the forging of the
great rings three were given to the
elves seven to the dwarflords and nine
nine rings were gifted to the race of
men oh it's on video
the lasso Nastya compels you to fear
slight meats back on the menu boy
[Music]
horses and a man on fire and I killed a
guy with a trident